tu sais que ketty n'est pas toujours
facile à vivre je tiens à ce qu'elles
travaillent pour nous c'est une
entreprise familiale
tu veux rire travailler pour ma
belle-mère essai de punaises qui ne sait
pas où ça peut donner
je tenterai ma chance tu n'as rien à
perdre
ça va je vais réessayer parker je vous
présente qu'éthique castle
oui la fille du président j'ai eu
quelques idées pour ses preuves
les boutons de mon temps on appelait ça
un succès elles m'ont volé mes idées qu
elle est chiche une moi et j'ai marché à
100% je ne peux même plus travailler
dans l'entreprise familiale
tu dois retourner chez castle sous les
traits de quelqu'un qu'ils écouteront et
qu'ils prendront au sérieux
ned ganymede j'ai rendez vous avec l'ica
seuls les cas seuls vous êtes attendus à
la réception votre rendez vous à 14
heures là il est dans une forme
olympique ronde se seraient pas déjà
rencontré pas dans cette vie
daniel tu devrais te joindre à nous
maurice organise une fête on ne le
laisse pas choisir le mieux alors quel
dommage qu'il soit hétéro
voici le curriculum de n'être
fouillaient la longeur semaine one
giorno gauthier et aussi tout le monde
adhère nietzsche commence à lui mais moi
aussi
ravissante un truc sur la joue au oui
c'est une bandelette démaquillant tuto
priante
mais doit avoir de la difficulté à
choisir une rapide
je sais les voies
pas jo dont nous allons accepter l'offre
de colline vous ne pouvez pas vendre
castle il a toute notre collection ce
qui se passe vignoble non moi je pense
que tu mignonne
je n'arrête pas de penser à elle ça
semble trop beau pour être vrai